Hello.
My name's Alison Rich.
Today we're gonna be talking
about Edie Windsor
and the end of DOMA,
the Defense of Marriage Act.
Cheers. Come on.
Cheers!
I feel like
I could puke tonight.
You know what?
Let's do it.
Tonight's the night to puke.
Yeah. Let's just get it
all out of us.
So the year is 1950.
The place is
the United States of A.
At this point in history,
it's not even legal
to dance closely to a person
of the same sex.
So Edie Windsor
was a young lesbian.
She's like, “Oh, I gotta keep
my personal life private,
'cause this is the past,
and the past is closed-minded”"
So then -
I'm talking about gay stuff.
[Laughs]
So then, Edie is
in Greenwich Village,
and she notices a beautiful,
leggy brunette.
She goes, “Hey.
Are you...
Can I dance with you?”
The woman goes, “Hello. My name
is Thea Spyer, and yes.”
That's a great name.
We've got Edie Windsor
and Thea Spyer.
Two, like, cool lesbian names.
Yeah.
You know?
And then Edie goes,
“Is your dance card full?”
Which is an old-timey way
of being like, “You single?”
And she goes, “It is now.”
Meaning, “I'm ready to...
bump clams.”
[Laughs]
Is that... I don't know
if that's offensive.
A clam? No. They have
pearls in them.
Yes.
Pussy pearls!
So then they date,
and they fall in love.
But then, on June 28, 1969,
she encounters
the Stonewall riots,
where gay people
were being out and proud
about who they were
amid this police raid
at the Stonewall Inn.
So she goes home
and she's like,
“Thea, there's a big riot
at Stonewall about gay rights.
Maybe this is the moment
that we should come out
and - and tell the world
who we really are.”
So she's like, “Hmm.
I don't know.
That's really risky.
Maybe not.”
So Edie and Thea are like,
“You know what?
We're not revolutionaries.
We're just two ladies.
We're in love
and like to dance, and we're
gonna be private about it.”
And they do that
for the next 30 years.
That's a long time.
And the thing that
they really bonded over
was dancing.
In any situation, their
bodies could always connect
through dance.
And it's about 2007 now,
and Thea was in a wheelchair
with M.S.
Thea was like,
“I want to get married.”
By this time, Canada had
made gay marriage legal.
So Thea and Edie
go to Toronto,
and they get married
in front of six buddies.
They exchange rings,
and Edie and Thea
are like, “Whoa.
This feels different.
To truly be married, like...
There's a tangible difference.
This is not bullshit.”
That's very sweet
to be like, I'm...
To flaunt the laws.
Yeah!
“F**k those laws.”
So in 2009, Thea dies.
And Edie is there
in the hospital,
and she's like,
“You know what?
I had a good life.
We had a beautiful love.
What more could I ask for?”
And then:
“Knock, knock, knock!”
The U.S. government says,
“Hey! So you're friend Thea
left you a bunch of
property, money, assets.
And we don't recognize that,
'cause you're two ladies.
It's not like
you were married,
so we're gonna tax you
on the order of half a millio”"
And Edie goes, “Bitch,
you know we were married,
and this is
discrimi-f**king-nation.
I'm gonna call
a bunch of lawyers.
I'm gonna call a bunch
of gay rights activists.”
Um, so then she says,
“Excuse me,
I was in a relationship
with this woman for forever.
We got married in Toronto.
This is legit.
They're not recognizing
the marriage,
and they're trying
to tax the shit outta me.”
And the lawyers
and activists are like,
“Yeah. That's DOMA, you know?
Since 1996, this law
was enacted that says,
on a federal level, a marriage
is between a man and a woman,
and it's just unde...
indefeatable. Undefeatable?
In...?
You can't do it.”
But then Edie calls
Roberta “Robbie” Kaplan.
Is her name
Roberta “Robbie” Kaplan?
Her fun name is Robbie.
Oh.
Her name is Roberta Kaplan.
And this woman goes,
“You know what?
I'll take you on.
You're what
marriage is about.
You two were married
for decades,
through sickness
and in health.
You're a sweet old woman.
You're the perfect example
of what gay marriage can be.”
So Roberta and Edie...
Mm-hmm.
...sue the federal government,
and it goes all the way
to the Supreme Court.
And Edie goes
before them and says,
“If my love isn't real,
no f**king love is real.
We were together for so long.
Our love deserves to be
recognized.”
Wow.
[Laughs]
It's actually
very classy.
OK.
[Laughs]
So on June 26, 2013,
Edie and her supporters
gather around a computer.
Pops up on the screen:
“DOMA is unconstitutional,
5-4.”
And everyone's like, “Woo!
Ooh-ooh!”
[Cheering]
“If I cheer too hard,
I'm gonna pee my pants.”
So she goes back to Stonewall
in Greenwich Village.
And crowds were gathered,
and they went,
“Edie! Edie! Edie!”
And Edie thought to herself,
“Wow. Years ago,
when I walked past here
during the Stonewall riots,
me and Thea thought,
we're not revolutionaries.
But here we are, years later,
and we are
the revolutionaries.
We're the face of what
gay marriage can be.”
And Edie dances
one last dance
in the name of the love
of her life,
Thea.
To Thea!
To Thea.
And Edie.
Whoa!
It's beautiful.
That's amazing.
Thanks to this
one brave woman
and her belief in
the equality of her love,
gay marriage became legal.
Do you think,
in memory of them,
that you and I should dance?
We should dance so close.
Well, can I give you
a quick peck?
[Laughs]
One...
Two...three!
Mwah!
Awwww.